So how would you use explanation based learning to implement an agent to
can solve Raven,s progressive matrices? The first question you're asking here is
what exactly are you explaining? Are you explaining the answer to the problem,
or are you explaining the transformations between figures in the earlier stages
of the problem? Given that, what new connections are you learning,
Is it learning performed within the problem or
old connections an justify the figure to fill in the blank, or
to perform the cross problems, where new transmissions and
types of problems can be learned and connected together.
For example you might imagine that you've encountered two problems before,
one are rotation and one are reflection. A new problem might involve both,
how do you use those earlier problems to explain the answer to this new problem?